bienvenue sur inch'allah airlines notre
température sera de 35 degrés à notre
arrivée à pattaya la bataille à vous
plaît ici c'est le paradis des cailleras
comment savoir s'il le fallait que je
prends un ballo tu jettes à il ou elle
toit et la passion me suis dit si jamais
contrôler le ballon poitrine et et est
elle fait pas du théâtre la rue mais ça
veut dire un liteon vous présente ma
part je contiens docteur voter mon amour
puis faire des gosses est temps ça me
dérange pas notamment puisque à la une
thèmes en fait de mon frère tu fais pas
mais ils ont des particularités m'a dit
toi ta meuf a été prolongée obama
deviendra une petite table quoi